the Prime Minister Boris Johnson has now
been discharged from hospital as he
continues his recovery from kovat 19
while we can bring in our political
correspondent Jay Pike to tell us more
about it a very good news for the prime
minister that he's been discharged from
hospitals Jay we understand he's on his
way to checkers but he's not going to be
immediately returning to work no this is
the full statement from Downing Street
in the last few minutes Sam the PM has
been discharged from hospital continue
to continue his recovery at checkers
checkers of course the Prime Minister's
official country residents on the advice
of his medical team the PM will not be
immediately returning to work he was
just to thank everybody at son Thomas's
for the brilliant K he has received all
of his thoughts are with those affected
by this illness now we know the Prime
Minister spent three nights in intensive
care and that in itself I think suggests
quite how bad his situation more than
his health was at some stage he clearly
has said overnight that he owes his life
to the medical staff absent Thomas's and
therefore I think it's very clear he
will need quite some time possibly a
number of weeks to recover we know that
his pregnant fiancee Carrie Simmons has
also shown symptoms of a cove at 19 and
has recovered so we perhaps presume that
she will also join the prime minister at
checkers to help with his recovery of
course some serious questions of the
government at the moment around lots of
issues including testing and personal
protective equipment and we know towards
the end of next week the government's
expert group of scientists saij will be
meeting to look at the key data in
relation to the outbreak and certainly
come to some early adviser and produce
some early advice for the government on
where NEX of course the government need
to make a decision in the next few weeks
about what to do with a lockdown how and
if to lift it it seems unlikely it will
be lifted in the immediate week more
likely that it will be extended but what
is the strategy for lifting it at some
stage I think Boris Johnson will want to
be at the heart of those decisions at
heart of those meetings but that clearly
could take some weeks
we Joe well we know that in his absence
has been deputized by a Dominic Rob and
will continue to see that arrangement
will be yeah that is the presumption for
now so Dominic Rob is the foreign
secretary but also the first secretary
of state he has been deputizing for the
Prime Minister but let's be honest there
haven't been a lot of very big decisions
to make in the past week while Boris
Johnson has been hospitalized the
machinery of government has continued
and the direction of travel set by Boris
Johnson before he was became ill was
very very clear the direction in terms
of testing in terms of PPE the lockdown
measures clearly are already in place so
Dominik robbed while he has been at the
helm he has been chairing those daily
kovin 19 meetings and he is the most
senior cabinet minister now he has not
needed to make any decisions I think we
know Boris Johnson is somebody who's
wanted to be in number 10 for his whole
life he knows that his Premiership will
be judged on his response to the covert
19 outbreak I think he will find it very
difficult and not to be at the forefront
of that decision-making we know though
that his close advisors civil servants
and political advisors know he needs
rest and he's only going to be able to
function at his peak if he has had a
time to rest at checkers in the coming
days and weeks ok Joe thank you just a
reminder that we know this information
because we've had a statement from
number 10 and that reads the PM has been
discharged from hospital to continue his
recovery at checkers on the advice of
his medical team the PM will not be
immediately returning to work
he wishes to thank everybody at st.
Thomas's for the brilliant care he has
received all of his thoughts are with
those affected by this illness
so just to recap the Prime Minister has
now been discharged from Thomas's
Hospital and is on his way to check us
to continue his recovery we wish him
well